(protester leader speaking
in foreign language)
(protesters speaking in foreign language)
(protester leader speaking
in foreign language)
- [Narrator] Imagine if your bank accounts
were frozen without warning.
(protesters speaking in foreign language)
Or you've been paying for an apartment
that hasn't been built.
That's happening in China
where economic woes have
pushed people to the streets,
and some people online, like
homeowners who are threatening
to stop paying their mortgages
until developers clear construction delays
and hand over the homes they bought.
China's GDP growth was close to zero
during the second quarter
amid COVID lockdowns
and supply chain issues.
These protests highlight specific troubles
and parts of China's economy.
So here's what's happening
and how the authorities
are trying to keep things under control.
(protesters clamoring)
(apprehensive music)
In China, there's been no
room for political protests
to challenge the leadership.
Just look at Beijing's suppression
of Hong Kong's pro-democracy
movement since 2019.
(protesters speaking in foreign language)
But the protests this
summer are different.
- This shows the recent
pattern mass protest in China
'cause people have
immediate issues to address
that really affect themselves directly.
- [Narrator] Tai Zixue
is an associate professor
who's been studying social
activism in China for 20 years.
He says protestors can't target
the ruling communist party
if they want to be heard.
- If you have political demands,
there's no room for negotiation
but the scenarios we
have seen are different.
They're not political; they're economic
or financial interest driven.
- [Narrator] One major issue
has been the country's real estate sector.
Collectively, urban Chinese
have nearly 78% of their wealth
tied up in residential property.
And many have yet to see their new homes
because developers don't have enough money
to finish building
apartments they've pre-sold.
To get a sense of how homeowners
have been left waiting in limbo,
take a look at this chart.
The blue line shows the
number of housing projects
that started construction in 2021.
The red line is the number of projects
that have been completed.
There are few reasons for this.
First, the government's strict limits
on property developers' leverage
cause some of them to
default on their debt.
Add on top of that, the slowing
economy and COVID lockdowns
that triggered a drop in home sales
which fell nearly 40% in
July compared to last year.
As a result, many developers
have had less cash
to fund construction.
(light music)
So frustrated fires of unfinished homes
have joined a movement
that's been gathering steam
on Chinese social media.
These are hundreds of joint
letters issued by homeowners
for more than 100 cities
across the country.
They've been circulating online
and all of them share a similar message
that they'll stop their mortgage payments
until developers finish and
hand over the apartments.
The mortgage revolt left
authority scrambling
to reassure home buyers that
projects will be completed.
Some local governments rolled
out tax rebates, cash rewards,
and lower down payments to
boost their property markets.
- It's tradition, Chinese protests.
You have to make a very
loud voice to get heard.
(protesters speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] Another problem
that's triggered loud complaints, thanks.
In the city of Zhengzhou,
protestors vented their anger
at rural lenders for
freezing their accounts.
This comes amid a government investigation
into financial misconduct by
a private investment group.
- Their immediate deal is
to get their money back.
They're not asking
anything more than that.
(protesters clamoring)
- [Narrator] Chaos erupted
when a group of unidentified
men in white T-shirts
ramped into the crowd.
The Wall Street Journal couldn't
determine their identity
and neither the bank
nor the local government
responded to request for comment.
The incident went viral
on Chinese social media
and got the attention of the authorities.
That's when local officials stepped in
and made concessions to
appease demonstrators
with two rounds of
repayments to depositors.
- They are giving indications
that the government is
working with those issues.
That's the typical strategy.
(bright music)
- [Narrator] For China's leaders,
maintaining stability is
a top economic priority.
So to stop the protest from growing,
the country's top policy-making
body said it would work
to resolve problems in
the rural banking system.
And it told local governments
to take direct responsibility
for delivering unfinished homes
and supporting demand for housing.
- So without finding ways
to keep the economy going,
more problems will show up.
This may be the opportunity
for them to figure out,
okay, what's the best way to move forward.
And also to find ways
into the national economic
policy to solve those issues.
- [Narrator] Stability is also the back
to our president Xi
Jinping needs as he tries
to secure a precedent-breaking
third term in a few months.
(apprehensive music)